E＆Sコレカラ
メソニック独自のテノスタッカートを飾りたくない、または私
が引き締めることができる私は私たちに会わなければなりませ
ん 日本の
マンションでマンションを購入した方法について
知りました。照明と
すべてが少し異なって見えるかもしれません。
明らかに棚
はまだここにありません。それは
私が新しいオフィスにいるので、新しいスタジオにいるのでお詫び
します。 来週
かそこらですべてが稼働
することを望んでいるので
、質問に直接入りましょう。
質問がたくさんあり
、適切に分類する時間がなかったので
、 質問の内容に関してはある程度の冗長性があります
が、ええと
、私は得たすべての質問に答えようとしているので、すぐに始め
ましょう。最初にアプリケーションを開いてみましょう。
econd okay um YouTube OK物件を購入するに
は、日本国民である必要
がありますか？最初のビデオでこれに答えます。
これに関連する質問はたくさんありません。
簡単にして、ノーと言います。 あなたは外国人になることができませんか？
非常に関連性のあるより詳細な質問が出
てくるので、質問は、日本人の私のアメリカ人のパートナーと結婚しなくて
も、外国人として日本に家を所有することさえ可能であるということです。
私は一緒になって9年に
なりますが
、4、5年でこのプロセスを自分たちでやりたいと思っていますが、
それは私たちにとっても可能性があるので
、日本人と結婚していない場合
でも、不動産を購入できますか？ 日本と
答えはイエスです私も
最初のビデオでこれに答え
ますが、あなたが日本に永住権を持ってい
て、日本人と結婚しなくても永住権を取得できる限り、あなたが日本と結婚している
ならそれは助けになります
日本国民
は、永住権を取得するプロセスをより早くするのに役立ち
ますが、それを取得
するために日本国民と結婚する必要はない
ので、一度取得する
と、通常
、生活を始めるのに約10年かかります 日本では
犯罪はなく、
適切な税金をすべて
払うことを知っています。基本的に、銀行
は通常の日本人とまったく同じようにあなたを扱い
ます。パートナー
が日本人でなくてもそうです。 あなたが9年間一緒にいる市民で、あなたは
4、5年でこのプロセスをやりたいと言っているので、
あなたが日本にどれくらい滞在しているかはわかりません。
パートナーと一緒
ですが、日本に
10年ほど
滞在している場合は、永住権を申請できます。永住権を取得した
場合は、日本で土地や不動産、家
やコンドミニアムを購入
できます。次の質問は結婚しています。 ネイティブそれはどのように
影響しましたか ローンと購入のプロセス
それはあなたのローンと購入のプロセスにどのように影響しました
か？あなたが
未婚または外国人の配偶者がいた場合と比べて、
私はちょうどこの質問に答えました
が、そうでない場合は永久居住がありません
その後、日本人と結婚することで
、多くの銀行は
、あなたが3年以上日本人と結婚しているかどうかを確認するのに役立ちます。
彼ら
は、それを一種の基準として使用して、
あなたが知っているように見えるかどうかを確認します。
日本の状況は安定し
てい
て、離婚することはないだろうし、物事は順調に進んでいる
ので、私が日本人と結婚していなかったとしたら、どうすればいいのでしょうか。
先ほどお話
したとおり、永住権を申請する必要があったと
思いますが、日本人と結婚していなければ、それを取得するのに約1年
かかりまし
た。 この時点で9年
o日本人と結婚することは
間違いなく助けになりました。
これからも続けましょう
。1回の返済があれば、クレジットシステムに話しかけて
ください。その他の
関連する詳細はアメリカから来ている
ので、提供できるコントラストは
非常に役立ちます。 私は
今、日本の婚約者と一緒に東京に住んで
いて、家族を育てるために田舎に引っ越そうとし
ているので、最初のビデオでこれについて少し話しましたが、
実際には州で不動産を購入したことがない
ので、
そのシステムについてはあまり詳しく
話すことはできませんが、私が詳しく話すことができるの
は、現在の日本の料金が
一般的に米国の州よりもはるかに低いということと非常に似ていることを理解しています
ローンの金利のような条件そして
またあなたが日本の婚約者と結婚しているのであなたは
日本人と関わって
います申し訳ありませんがそれは
私が前に述べたようにあなたを大いに助けます
私はあなたがどれくらいの期間かわかりません ve 結婚している
が、うまくいけば、あなたの状況は再びスムーズに進む
と思います。あなたは、あなたが下に置くことができるほど、あなたが最初
に下に置くことができるより多くのお金をあなたが
ローンを得ることができる可能性が高いので、私は本当に
正確にどれくらいかわかりません もっと私は
彼ら
が過去2年間の基本的にすべてのあなたの
税歴とそのようなものを見るクレジットシステムについて話す
必要が
あります 質問
です。多額の借金のような未払いの借金がない限り
、たとえば私の妻は学生ローンを持っていたので
、彼女はまだ返済
を続けています。私は今彼女の返済を手伝っていますが、私たちはすでに車を返済しています。 私
たちが持っている唯一の借金は家族です
私の妻の
15時30分を完済することです20
年の学生ローンだと思い
ますが、ローンを申請する直前に
、3分の1のように完済しました。
一見を完済したかった その大部分です
が、彼らは私にあなた
が今返済する必要のある借金があるかどうかを明確に尋ねました
、そして私は基本的に
私の妻がまだ彼女の学生の借金を返済しているのでは
なく、私が車を返済していたならええと言いました
そして多分他のいくつかの大きな
購入もおそらく私はおそらく
ローンを得ることができなかった
でしょう、それであなたは大丈夫です次の質問に進みましょう
私が考えることができないプロセスについて聞くことは非常に興味深いでしょう
地方の価格帯と日本人と結婚し
ていない外国人のローン要件以外の具体的な質問は
大丈夫なので
、これについてはすでに話しました
が、私がマンションを所有しているマンションの価格帯について話します。
私は今、田舎の日本であるBeppu Japanにいます
が、おそらく東日本で購入した場合の
少なくとも2倍の費用がかかるとしましょ
う。おそらく、神奈川出身です。 千葉の
ように私が何人かの人々を知っているように
東京の外にある千葉に住んでいると、
東京から電車で1時間
くらいで45分くらいで、
そこでも2倍
くらいで、東京の真ん中にいると2倍くらいで
、 オクラホマ、東京、大阪など
の主要な大都市の1つに住むことに夢中になっている場合を除いて、半分以上はそう
ではありません。屋外や地方で購入することを強くお勧めします。
あなたのお金はもっと
遠くに行くでしょうあなたはあなたのお金
があなたのためにもっと働くことができるでしょうそれで私
はもう一度
私たちがやったことが少しあると
答えたと思います
きちんと整理する時間がなかったので、
できる限り早く
やり遂げているので
、市民権のスラッシュビザに関して不動産を購入することについて提起しています。
それでもポットはあなたがし
なければならないものです 更新することは外国人がすることは可能ですか
永住者として登録してください。
そうすれ
ば、外国人は永住権を取得できます。
現在、配偶者ビザのようなビザを取得する前に、これについて話しました。
私のビザステータスは、日本人と結婚して
おり、そのビザは
更新期間が異なる
ため、最初の3年間は最初の3年間は毎年更新する必要がありますが、3年間
更新した後
は、次の
期間に更新できます。  3年なので、私は
現在、
その3年の更新の約半分でその3
にいます。その後
、永住権を申請するだけ
です。その配偶者ビザを再度申請することはできない
ので、おそらく5年のようになります。
しかし、私の状況に基づいて、私が
それをかなり簡単に申請した場合、私はおそらくこの時点で永住権を
取得することができます私はここに子供を持っています私の妻の日本人私は
ええ働いているのでおそらくそれを
申請するでしょう et
永久居住と私はまだ
私のビザを更新する必要がありますが、私は永久居住を取得したらすぐにはしません
大丈夫私たちが時間通りにそれをどのように行う
か見てみましょう
自分で検索するの
が好きでしたか不動産業者があなたをどのように扱ったかが好き
だったので、
不動産業者は私たちをとてもよく扱ってくれ
ました。 私
は最初のビデオでもこれについて少し話し
ましたが、コンドミニアムを売ることは彼らの利益になることを知っています。
彼らは私を、財政だけで
なく潜在的に購入する財政を持っている人として見たと思います
でも私は
、日本人
がとても上手で、
私の納税者のように見えたので、コンドミニアムを買うことができる状況にいると
彼らが感じていたと思います。 大丈夫のようにこの男は
おそらく 長い間ここにいるので、
彼はおそらく
息子を買うのに良い状況にあるようです。もしあなた
が入って、あなたが日本人と結婚して
いなかったら、あなたは永住権を持っていなかった
でしょう。多分あなたは日本にしかいなかったでしょう。
5年ほどの間
、あなたの税金の領収書と
私たちが本当に混乱しているすべてのことは、
これは
私たちにとって価値があるよりも多くの仕事になるだろうと
思うかもしれません。
それは
私の個人的な状況の詳細の
ためです。心に留めておいてください。
関連する質問を続けましょう。
日本の賃貸人
や売り手売り手の
ようなあらゆる種類のひどい話を聞いたことがあります。 いい
質問ですね。これをどうやってカバーするかはよくわかりません。私は
日本に住んでいます。
日本は実際には誰も知らない最高の税率
ですが、実際には
外国人と日本人の比率
が最も高いのです。
モール比較的小さな町約
10万人12万人
ですが、ここには国際大学があり
、学生の半数が
海外から来ており、観光地でもあり
、温泉などを知っている人がいつも別府にやって来ます。
そういうわけで、
国際大学の卒業生の多くは、APにとどまるか
、大学がAPUと呼ばれる地域にとどまることに決めている
ので、別府の人々は
外国人との付き合いに慣れています。
東京や
オクラホマなので、個人的に
は日本全国どこでもそういう差別などをし
たことはあり
ませんが、外国人も比較的馴染みのある場所に行ったことも
あるので
、 東京や大阪、
あるいはこれらの主要都市の1つに
反対していて、私はコカコーラ湾に
いるので、おそらく問題にはなり
ませんが、少し同じ大きさの小さな都市にいる場合は、
観光地ではないか
、国際大学がないか
、ベルが鳴っているのが残念です。
すぐに戻ってくる
ので、NHギャグNHKの男が文字通り
ここに来ました。
私はこのビデオを撮影しているので
、彼の面倒を見
てから、戻って録音を終了
します。そうですね、アパートに住むことに関しては、いかなる種類の差別にも対処したことはありません。
またはこの
場合、日本で土地のマンションを購入するので、
私はそれを扱ったことがありません。あなた
が大都市にいるなら、それはおそらく大したことではありません
が、あなた
がまだある場所で阿中に
いるのなら 外国人が多いし、
日本人が苦手な方は問題になるかもしれ
ませんし、人種差別とは関係ないので
、会社のシーンと関係があると思います。
儲かる儲かる投資ではなく
【音楽】
日本語が話せないなら会社
i 彼らはあなたともっと多くの時間を費やす
必要があり、彼らが外国人との
取引に慣れていないようで、彼らがあなたと適切に
コミュニケーションをとることができない場合、彼らはあなたを
断る可能性が高くなります。 あまり明瞭ではないので
、新しい場所の場所全体の表面積を続けましょ
う。両方とも大丈夫です。
これについて話さなければなりません。
古い場所のビデオツアーに参加するつもり
でしたが、走りました。
移動プロセスに当初の予想よりもはるかに時間がかかっている
ため、
残念ながら
そのビデオを作成
でき
ません。本当にお詫び申し上げます。 十分な時間がありますが
、私の古いアパートの表面積
とこの場所は実際には非常に
似ていますが、この場所は私の古い場所の
ようにちょうどよりよく整理されているので、この場所
はかなり良くなると思います
両方b この場所のツアービデオで見せたマスターベッドルームよりも大きいので、
そのうちの1つは私の
スタジオでしたが、実際には大きすぎて
、
サウンドがいたるところにあり
、リバーブが多かったため、使いづらかったです。 エコーして、物
を置く場所があまりない
ので、表面積
自体はかなり多いですが
、古い場所の
この場所にあります。物事の整理方法のレイアウトのために、この場所がとても好きです。
だから大丈夫
、私がとりとめのない場合は申し訳ありませんが、私は
5分ほど失ったので、今はちょっとプレッシャーにさらされ
ています。コーヒーもたくさん
ありました。 はい、私は
日本人と結婚していて、
結婚して3年以上になります。そのため、
銀行と政府は、基本的に
政府を知って
いることから、この男は
おそらく日本にいるだろうと考えています。  a 長い
間そうです私は安定した状況にあります
大丈夫続けましょう
あなたが雇用主からのビザではなく配偶者ビザを持っていたという違いがありました
これは
興味深い質問です それは
ある程度の違い
をもたらしました。つまり
、私は仕事よりもyoutubeからより多くのお金を稼いでいるので
、配偶者ビザを持っていたので違いがあったと言えば、
おそらく
私が言おうとしていることは
、後で別の質問でこれに答えるつもりです
が、ええと、私はそうだったでしょう。
日本で普通の仕事をしていれば普通の会社で普通に働いていたならこの場所を買うことができたので、
私の場合、配偶者ビザを持っていたので彼を助けまし
た。
何年も彼らは安定性を見ますが
あなたも 私の仕事のビザはとにかく5年間しか有効ではなかったことを知っている
ので、私の状況
では、通常の仕事以外に追加の収入
があり、特定の例では日本人と結婚しているので
、私の特定のケースでは役に立ちました
申し訳ありませんが、私の考えを明確にするのはとても悪いです。
続けましょう。
購入する家を探すときに探したものについて話してください。インフラストラクチャの構築などを借りる代わりに、家を買うとき
にさまざまなものを探す方法を知っています。
品質など日本
でどう変わったのか気に
なるので、これはいい質問です。
前の動画
で
お話ししたのですが、 素晴らしい眺め私
たちは4つの部屋がある場所が欲しかったので
、私のオフィスにマスターベッドルーム
があり、次に保管室
と最後のベッドルームがありますが、
おそらく10または15のように改装する予定です
双子が少し年を
とって、保管室を
別の寝室に
変えて
から、双子であるために必要のないものをどこかに移動
して、あなたが知っているようになったら
13 14 15
彼らはおそらく
自分のスペースが必要になるので、4つのベッドルームが
必要で、眺めが
良く、比較的新しい場所も
必要でした。また、私たちにとって大きな食器洗い機も
必要だったので、その質問を残しておきます。
この場所は新しいので、この場所
の構造の構造的完全
性などの地震の安定
性は非常に良いので、
私たちにとっても重要だと知っていましたが、
基本的に日本のすべての場所は
5年未満です 古い
もの
はどんな種類の地震でも絶対に問題
ないでしょうそれはあなたがノックオフするので大丈夫ですそれで
田舎の家はそれらのアキアキの1つを買うことを考えました
か
大丈夫
です
。35ヤードのローンをかわすことができたかもしれませんが、代わり
にリフォームに多くの時間とエネルギーを
費やしました。 だから私は
アキヤや
古い家のよう
に安くてもリフォームしなければ
ならなかったようなものを
買うことに興味がありませんでした。
25年か30年前のような日本政府
20年前のことはよく覚えていません
神戸
地震が起こった頃だったと思います大地震の際にすべてが大丈夫である
ことを確認したこの新しい法律の
ように通過したと思います
それ
だけ
でなく
、あなたが時間とあなたが言ったように本当に良い価格のようにリノベーションを得ることができたとしても、これらの古い場所の多くが
あなたが費やさなければならない努力
と改修に
それは私にとってそれは価値がないだけですそれは他の誰かのためかもしれませんが私にとってはそうではあり
ません私はただ
私が引っ越してすぐに働き始めることができる場所が欲しい
ので
私の状況はありません
Ikeaは大丈夫だとは思わない35年ローンは普通の
ことですそう
です前のビデオでもこれについて少し話しました
が、日本の標準的なローンの種類
は35年のフラットローンです
それは正常であり、
先に話したように一般的な金利は州よりもはるかに低い
ので、私は支払ってい
ます。今は0.85％の利子だったと思います。これは
変動ローンなので
、少し変わる可能性があります。
かなりの時間のように大きく変化し
ますが、興味深いことに、
これは大丈夫です。永住権
を持たない日本の外国人として
、銀行は
私を通常の日本人とまったく同じように扱ってくれません。
市民なので実際にできる
永住権を持っている場合や日本人の場合はさらに低い金利に
なるので、今は0.85
％です
が、永住者がいる場合はポイント6、5％、0.6％に
なる可能性がありますが、一度借り換えることができ
ます。 永住権を持っている
ので、今は金利がとても安いので、
借り換えに急ぐ必要はありません。
借り換えは、他の銀行でローンを
借りて最初のローンを返済し終え
たときです。
永住権を取得し
てから長い間、借り換えをして、新しいローン
を借りて、現在よりも高い金利の古いローンを返済する
ので、できるかどうかを知っておくと
よいでしょう。
永住権をお持ちの方や
日本人の方は低金利でご利用いただけますので、
始めたばかりで低金利ですが
、プロセスが長いので今は大したことではありませ
ん。 少しのお金を使うこと
長期的には
できるだけ低金利で
借り換えをするので、借り換えをします。35年
ローンは普通です。大丈夫です。
この人は日本の
パタヤのように穏やかに研ぎ澄まされたよう
に言っています。 チーとムスクなので
、問題は日本の外国人としては合理的
かという
ことです。彼らが言おうとしているのは
、普通の日本の会社で働いていれば、普通の日本の仕事に取り組むことです。
日本で素敵なコンドミニアムを手に入れることは可能ですか。
実はこれは本当にいい質問だと思います。
その理由は、
この
質問の答えはノーだと思うので、
少し前に話し
ましたが、ローンを組むことができた理由です。
私は2つの仕事をしているので、
オンラインでの仕事で通常の
日本の仕事よりもかなり多くのお金を稼いでいるので、
少し時間をかけてこれについて話します
。20歳から20歳までのほとんどの外国人だ
と思います。  30多分35しないでください
日本で大金を稼ぎます。その
理由はおそらくこれとは
別のビデオにすると思います。
これについては後で説明しますが、これの主な
理由は、
現在日本にいる外国人の需要によるものです。 かなり
低いので、英語の教育の仕事以外の仕事の面で
は、
翻訳の仕事のような
ものですが、そもそもそれらはそれほどうまくペイントされていません。
日本で設立されたのは、通常、
あなたが年をとってい
て、普通の会社に長くいるほど、より多くのお金
を稼ぐことができるので、
20代の誰かがおそらく
月に約2,000米ドルを稼ぐとしたら、それは
平均的で、30代のどこかで
おそらく3,000ドルから4,000ドルの
間40代の誰かがおそらく
4,000ドルから5,000ドルの間なので
、あなたが持っているスキルセットについてではなく、
あなたの
年齢についてです。 正しい用語ですが
、 日本の労働
システムの特徴であるため、日本人を含むほとんどの人は、私の
ように
複数の仕事をし、複数の収入源を持っていない限り、このよう
なマンション
を購入することはできません。 私のオンラインでの努力
と通常の仕事で、
この場所を取得することができ
ましたが、ほとんどの場合、
Google Japanのように仕事をしている場合や
、 あなたは日本であなた自身のユニークな
ビジネスをしている
あなたは起業家のようであり、あなたはあなた
自身のために非常にうまくやっ
ています 彼らは
おそらくかなり安くする必要があった
ので、
彼らが複数の仕事をしていて、複数
の収入源を持っていない限り、ええ、私は
おそらく、先に言ったように
、停止について話している別のビデオを使うつもりです。
非常に興味深い
ので、詳しく議論する価値があると
思いますが、
今のところはこれですべてです。これからも続けていきます。アメリカの
元本利子保険では、毎年、個人の納税申告書から税金
の利子を差し引くことができます。
プリンシパルダウンまたは
保険は、20％未満のダウンで大丈夫なので、
追加の月々の支払いです。
これは非常に複雑な質問です
。この人が尋ねていることのほとんどは、別の質問で答えたと思います。
私
は保険でいくつかの小さなことに触れるつもり
です私は保険の単一の全体的なパッケージのようなものを支払ってい
ますそれは
水害のようなもの
がある場合や風害がある場合や場合のようにカバーします
地震
か津波かなんか12年11年12年
くらいで千ドルくらいだった
と思う
のでかなり安いと思いますが
それかなんでも差し引けません そのように
あなたがあなたがあなたの税金を払うものに行動を起こすような点であなたがすることができる唯一の主要なこと
と
私は前のビデオでこれについて話しました、
しかしあなたはあなたがあなたを差し引くことができる
あなたの住宅ローンに残っている金額の1パーセントを取る
ことができます 年末に日本政府
に支払う必要のある金額から
それを差し引くことができる
ので
、前のビデオでそれについて話しました。もっと知りたい場合は、前のビデオを
見に行くことをお勧めします。
後半で
お話ししたと思いますので、35分で時間通りに進んでいきましょ
う。3分くらいで大丈夫です。
具体的すぎる
か、質問があるかもしれませんが、
快適に答えることができます。 アメリカに拠点を置く銀行口座と日本に拠点を置く口座の間で送金する
ことは不可能ではないにしても非常に難しいと聞いてい
ます。
私が日本で稼いだお金を受け取る
だけでなく、日本の請求書を支払うための日本語のnkアカウント毎月自動的に支払う
必要があるような多くのアパートや公共料金の請求書
家賃や公共料金のように支払うには日本の銀行口座が必要です
私自身のビジネスをオンラインで運営し、
そのお金は常に
私たちの中にあります ドルと私の米国の米国の銀行
口座に行きますあなたは
アメリカ
の口座と日本の口座の間で
その逆
に送金するのに問題があり
ましたか？
年間千ドルで大丈夫な
ので、この質問すべてに簡単に答えよう
と思います。PayPalを試して使用できるかどうかを考えてみて
ください。現在、オンラインで稼いでいるお金を
GoogleAdsenseのお金にしています。 私
がYouTubeを利用しているのは
ごく
わずかですが、月に150ドル
が私の日本の銀行口座に直接
入金されるようなもので、誰でも簡単に設定できますが
、パトレオンで稼いだお金が好きです。
PayPalアカウントに送金し、PayPalの料金を請求し
ます。パトレオンからそのお金を受け取るのに20ドルかかると思います。
それから
、それを他のさまざまな銀行口座すべてに送金するだけなので、
どのくらいの金額になるかを確認します。 私は
米国
と日本に銀行口座とさまざまなオンライン銀行
口座を持っています。通常
、PayPalで稼いだお金の約半分を受け取り、それを使って私の
ようなさまざまな日本の銀行口座に送金します。
銀行口座私の妻の銀行口座
はそのようなものですそしてそれから私は
米国にそのような
投資やそのようなもののための貯蓄口座
を持っていますあなたは私が子供を持っていることを知っ
ているので ええと
、PayPalは
、あなたがそれを使うことが
できれば、かなり良い選択肢だと思います。あなたが取ることができるのに、あなたはそうすることができ
ます。  1回の送金
が可能な最大額だと思いますが
、5万ドル程度の家を購入する場合を除い
て、ほとんどの人は10,000ドルで十分な
ので、よくわかりません。 私がこれに正しく答えて
いるのであれば、PayPalは良い
選択肢だと思い
ます。たとえば、PayPalアカウントから日本の銀行口座にお金を移動するためにお金を請求することはなく
、現在の為替レートの恩恵を受けることができるからです。
かなり良いですが、そうではありませんが、これを
どのように説明すればよいのでしょうか。
現在の為替レートが1ドルで130円
の場合、PayPalを使用すると通常1ドルあたり約115円に
なります。これは、スーパーが更新されないためです。
定期的にそれはとにかく私の理解ですので、まだたくさんの質問が残っている
ので、移動し続け
なければなりませんが、あなたが
どの県に住んでいるのか尋ねてもらえれば、PayPalが少し助けてくれることを願っていますはい私
はベットブーシティに住んでいます oタイプ
九州にある県
なので南西メジャーが日本の4大島の南西島の最後になりました。
地震
が多く津波につながることが多いので、日本は地震活動が多いので続けましょう。
彼女が海の近くにいたときにそれを考慮しましたか？
ビットブーは沿岸都市であるか、
それはあなたがそれを何と呼んでも港の町の家のようです
が、それは
山があり、かなりだったので、これは私たちにとって問題ではありませんでした
山の上の比較的高いところにあるので
、100メートルの津波のようなものでなければ、それは
私たちにとって問題ではないことを知っていますし、それがすぐに起こるとは思わないので、問題ではなかったと思います
私たちにとって
は、海のすぐ隣に住むつもりなら
、そう考える必要はありません。
まったく新しい
場所だったとしても、1階や3階のように住みたいとは思わないでしょう。
たぶん
4階もあると思います
私が
海のすぐ隣に住んでいて
、その構造的な
完全性のために新しい場所でなけれ
ばならない場合は、4階から5階以上です。外国人として日本で不動産を購入するための前提条件は何ですか。
あなたは国民である必要があります
かそれは一定期間そこに住んでいたか、または正規雇用を持っていたので、
私が詳細に話していない唯一のことは正規雇用である前に私は基本的にこれらすべてについて話しました
正社員になる必要があるので、今は正社員ではありません。
通常の仕事との契約は5
年間なので、銀行はそれを知っていまし
たが、私が追加で稼いでいることを知っていました。
ですから、彼らにとってはそれで十分だと思います
が、追加収入
がなければ通常の日本の給与のように基づいています。
標準的な
平均給与に基づいた安定性があると、再びうまくいくのは難しいでしょう。
それは、
あなたが行くつもりの価格帯に依存します。あなた
はマンションの価格で意図していますが、
正社員は
私が考えるのに役立ちます すべての状況ですが
、必ずしも大丈夫というわけではないので、最初の収入の流れがあれば、その質問に答える必要はないと思います。
私の質問の1つは、外国
人として一人で日本人と日本人との間に違いがあることです。
どのような追加の書類を記入する必要がありましたか？追加の
書類に関しては
、いくつかのフォームに記入する
必要がありました。私の場合、誰かが必要なようなものでした。
私の保証人のガランになったのは私の妻でした。
ho so nyanの発音を覚えておい
てください。あなたが日本語で言うのは
保証人ですが、保証人は英語で言う方法だと思います。
私に何かあったらこの人を言ういくつかのフォームが必要です
w ブロックの残りの部分は病気
なので、そのような書類をいくつか記入する必要がありました。また、
私はアメリカ市民であり、米国
政府は外国の資産などを所有する人々に対して非常に厳格である
ため、記入する必要がありました。
私の社会保障番号のようないくつかのフォームを出しまし
たが、それは
あなたが知っているような標準的なもののようなカップルでした
あなたの名前住所電話番号社会
保障番号を書いてくださいそしてそれはそれについてでし
た ローンを申し込むときは、それ以外にいくら
払わなければならないのか
、家を買う一般的なプロセスの説明をお願いしたいので
、前のビデオで一般的なプロセスをカバーしました
が、 最初の金額をいくら下げる必要があるかということ
は興味深い質問なので、実際
には個々の状況によって異なりますが
、日本で安定した仕事をしている人にとっては、
40代の誰かが
かなりのお金を稼いでいて、安定した
状況にある銀行は
その特定の状況で誰かを扱います彼らは
それはおそらく完全に問題ないと思うでしょう
安定性経済的安定性彼らは
ほとんど何も下に置く必要はありません私
はあなたが1ヶ月分の家賃のように下に置くことができると思います
が、いくらが
ローンに返済されるので、私の場合
それは私にはわかりません 毎月1,000ドルの
ように、
安定した収入
があり、毎月かなりの金額の収入があった
人は、ごくわずかな金額を下ろすことができました
が、私の
特定の状況のために、下に置くのに大いに役立ちました。
そもそもたくさんのお金
があります
が、コンドミニアムの価格にもよりますが、最初に物件にいくらお金をかけても、ユニット自体や家の価格に関係なく、平均的な
コンドミニアムを支払うことになると思います。
reは、約
10,000ドル相当の追加料金です。これ
は、取引手数料の
ようなもの
であり、弁護士がこの
フォームを作成して自分の
名前やそのようなものを
お金の外で作成するためにこの料金を支払う必要があるのと同じです。
基本的に
、日本で購入する状況では
、追加の1万
ドルが必要になるので、多くの税金を支払う必要はありません。
初期の固定資産税ですが、
何があっても少なくとも1万ドルは支払う必要
があるので、日本で家を購入するときに発生するさまざまな税金は何であるかを尋ねないでください。
請求書についてですが、税金以外
は日本に固定資産税があります
。IIは、ほとんどの場所で
10万ドルから30万ドルのように、毎年
固定資産税に支払う金額は5500ドルの間だと考えています。
ドルとおそらく$1,500
なので、追加の税金日本で不動産
を所有することに関連する追加の税金はないと
思います。ただし
、先ほど触れたものだけを知っているので、
それは正しいと
思います。 ユニットの修理費などの
料金や
、マンションの清掃費などは、
明らかに家の場合は必要ありません
が、コンドミニアムの場合は
、私にはわからないように追加料金を支払うことになります。
月額$100$ 200で、
あなたの質問に答えてくれるといいのですが、
44分続けましょう
私を引っ越した後にあなたが得るものだから、
私がその場所に来
て完全に空になった
直後にこれは面白いです私が入ったのは私だけ
でした かわいい
あなたの質問に
答える楽しい希望これは奇妙に聞こえるかも
しれませんが、外国人または
非永住者が
、私が検討しているローンではなく、完全な購入で完全な購入なしに日本で不動産を購入できるかどうかについて何か感覚がありますか？
日本で働くことに転職し
、ローンを組まなくても不動産を購入できる投資で幸運
だったので、もっと吹き飛ばされるのは、
ローンの重要な問題です。
現金を持っているなら
、ユニットをまっすぐに買うことができますか？私は
あなたが求めているものだと思います。
私の理解では、あなたが唯一のことをうまく理解できると信じて
います。 現金
ですぐに購入できる
でしょう。
誰かが関連する質問をした追加の問題に遭遇することはない
と思います。それについては後で詳しく説明します
ので、
続けましょう。 今30分
実際にNHKの時間に35分かかるとしたら
多くの日本の家
ではオーブンパーティーがないことに気づきます
特に高価なものや
特定の高価なものや見つけるのが難しいもの
はありませんか
人々は
、誰かに焼いて調理するのが好きな人に聞いてもらうことを本当に気に
しないので、私にはかなり奇妙に
思えます。そのため、プルダウン
を知っている州のように、これらのオーブンはそれほど多くあり
ません。
多くの人が実際に
電子レンジをオーブンとして使用しています。なぜなら、彼らはマイクだからです。
日本のほとんどの電子レンジは、
オーブンの機能
のようなものです。
でもオーブンとしては
小さなオーブンのようなものなので、日本のほとんどの場所で
は標準のオーブン
がユニットに組み込まれていませんが、ほとんどの人は、
最終的
には400500または電子レンジのようになり
ます。  eそして彼らはオーブンとしての
追加機能を持っているのでその電子
レンジを使用しますそして代わりにそれを使用し
ます私
は
3、4年前に私の電子レンジに200ドルのように支払っ
たように私が支払ったと思います 大丈夫だということを知っておく必要があり
ます。
ローンを組むようなショックを受けたり
、同様の用語であるショックを受けたりするので、
漢字のように、この特定の部分に彼を入れなければならないかもしれません。
でも
彼女はあなたをクインし、両方を押し込む
ということは本質的に
お金を借りてお金を借りるという意味
です
漢字は一目瞭然ですが、今まで見たことがなかった
ので、質問がいくつあるかを知っておくといいでしょう。
私は何も持っていない
ので 住人が多く、日本人の
妻がいない
ので、ラップトップで仕事をしているので、日本で
はあまり働きません。先ほど、銀行から
20万ドルの住宅ローンの形で、現金でコンドミニアムを購入してもいいかと尋ねられました。
それを使って日本の場所を買うことができますか？
その質問の答え
はそうだと思いますが、そうするつもりです。
ある種の主要な規定が
あります。それは、
お金を入れて日本の銀行に200を与える場合です。
日本の銀行ではなく
、不動産業者
がすでにそのお金を持っている
ので、あなたが返済できない場合に何が起こるかを気にしないので、
あなたはあなたの母国のあなたの銀行にそのお金を知っています。
すでに鉱山を持っていますが、
あなたが母国の銀行にそのお金を返済することができず
、彼らが
日本に管轄権や権限を持っていない
場合は、その銀行が日本に来て
、
私たちが行くことを知っていると言うのではなく
あなたはもういないのであなたからあなたの財産を奪う
rおそらく刑務所に行くことになり、
おそらく犯罪と見なされる可能性がある場所を返済できる状況では
、
日本の不動産業者に
多額のお金を与えることができたとしても、 技術的に場所を購入する
銀行の各国の法的な境界のためにそれが実行可能なオプションに
なるとは思わないので、私はまったくお勧めしません私は
あまりにも複雑になると思い
ます 近い将来、東京の学校に通うことを考えている都市の外に住む
ことができるように、どのような仕事をしているのか聞いてもかまいません。
東京が
大好きな間
は、外での生活を楽しんでいると思います。
市外、特に農村部で仕事を見つけるのが
どれほど難しいか心配だと言ったので、これについては別のビデオを作成します。
日本では1時間
くらいですが ええと、私はこれをします私は
パトレオンで日本語を教えるたくさんのオンラインのことをします
私はYouTubeでコメディービデオをします私は
オンラインで翻訳の
ようなものをしていました
しばらく前に書いた電子書籍のよう
に、通常の仕事以外のオンラインでの仕事がたくさんあります。
日本の高等教育機関で働いているので、日本中にいる
必要のないものがたくさんあります。 東京ですが、
実際にそのような場所でかなりの数の求人があるかどう
かはわかりませんが、これ
については今後さらに詳しく説明します。私は高等教育機関で働いています。
オンラインでも仕事を続けましょうこれを続けましょう前者
を選ぶ理由を考えさせ
られました日本人から
日本人から
コンドミニアムで財産税を節約でき、もちろん集中型の
ようないくつかの利点があると言われました
ガベージシステム集中
秒 しかし、主
な質問は
、マンションの管理
者が居住者に建物全体を倒して新しい建物を建てるために合法的に退去を求めることができるようになる前に、マンションの所有権を何年受けることができるかということです。
その場所にある
ので、特に日本がどのように
建設されているかを見ると大丈夫なので
、正確な数を思い出せ
ないので、これは20年ほどで完全に間違っているかもしれません
が、
45年は平均の長さだと思います
マンションが倒壊する
前に日本にあったので
、45年後には70歳くらいに
なるので、とにかく別の場所に
いると思います。
45 46 47になるので、彼らは
そのように自分たちで生活するので
、40年くらいだと思います45
年はとにかく私
がビジネスビザを持っていれば
それがそうであったように銀行を助けるでしょう あなたのマールと riageは
大丈夫なので、基本的には先に答えたと思いますが
、ビザが何であるかは問題ではありません。
安定している必要があるので、
結婚と追加収入
による安定性、または安定した収入の安定した雇用を知っている仕事による安定性
安定している限り、予見可能な将来のビザ
はそれほど重要ではあり
ません。毎月、家賃
と同じくらいの額の
クレジットを支払う必要が
あります。あなたが求めているのは、それ以上の金額だと思います。
お金を
払っていますか？
これには、コンドミニアムに関連するすべてのもの
が含まれるため、元本を含む利息が含まれます。これには
、ごみの清掃サービスなどのさまざまな料金が含まれます。
修理費清掃費
1,000ドル前後の質問に答えて
くれるといいのですが、個人の財政で
保険について話せるからといって、あまり詳しくは説明しません。先ほど
、11ドル
または200ドルについて話しました。 この場所の損害保険パッケージの種類は12年か10年だったかもしれ
ません私
が知っている他の追加の保険はないと
思います日本国民と結婚する以外に日本に永久に住む方法について話してもらえますか
あなたが働いている会社が後援しているのかもしれないので
、これについては別のビデオで
も話すでしょうが、もしあなたが日本市民と結婚していなければ、そう
です。
日本で約10年間一貫して働いており、その10年間
、さまざまな企業または単一の企業から後援を受けている限り
、永住権を申請することができます。
それを手に入れることができ、その時点で永住権を取得すると
仕事をやめて日本に
住むことができます。永住権を取得
するので、会社があなたをバックアップする必要はありませんが、
停止した場合はすべてのCPUが必要になります。 働い
て税金を払うのをやめる
と、マイナスの影響が出るでしょう。
日本の気候と昆虫はどれほど悪いのか、
50人を殺した拳の側面にハチがいると聞いています。
ええ、日本には巨大なハチがたくさんあり
ますが、実際にはかなり頻繁に見られますが、それほど大きな問題ではありません
が、コンドミニアムを持っていることのクールな点の1つは
、6、7、8階のように上に来たら
見たことがない大きな虫のほとんどは、
続けて
行きましょう。あなたの職場
もローンの手続きに影響を与えていると思い
ますか。私が働いている場所
はかなり立派で、
評判が良いです。 日本だから私
私の追加収入に加えて、私の追加収入に
加えて
、銀行は
おそらく見たと思います、そして彼らは大丈夫、この
男は日本で適切な仕事
だと言ったと思います
私の勤務先は、日本でのローン
の取得にプラスの影響を与えました。
あなたはどのような生活の手配をしてきまし
たか。今まで賃貸アパートに住んでいましたか。そうだとすれば、
その状況はどのように異なりますか。
大丈夫だからあなたは所有していないので年末に控除を使用することはできません
また日本のほとんどのアパート日本の新しい
アパートは
2つのldkのように大きくないので2つのリビング2つの
ベッドルームとかなり広いリビング 部屋がある
ので
、日本で3つの
寝室のような新しいアパートを見つけるのは非常に難しいので
、もちろん借りるのとは対照的に、あなたの場所で実際に所有する喜びは別として知っ
て
おくとよいでしょう。 私たちが日本に
非常に長い間滞在することを知っています。すでに
月額800ドルまたは750ドルを家賃に支払っている場合は、それを場所の所有
に向けて試してみることもできます。これも
、私たちが実際に決めた主な理由の1つです。
大丈夫購入し続けましょうそう
です大きな違いの1つは私たちがそれを所有し
、追加のベッドルームもあること
ですアパートを見つけることができないので新しいアパート新しい素敵なアパート
多くのベッドルームがあります私も
知りたいです どうやって日本で就職したのですか。
これについては別のビデオでお話しします
が、ジェットプログラムに3年間在籍して
いたので、
観光ビザで日本と韓国を行き来し
ました。 日本に戻っ
て塾で1年間英語を教えた
後、通常の仕事を
始めてからyoutubeを始めました。それが今日の私です。
それ
については、別のビデオで詳しく説明します。
私は賃貸人でもあります。 すでに
答えたので大丈夫です 人生
でこの巨大なサミットに到達した今の
あなたの目標は何ですか私はこれからも
続けていきたいです
私は誇りに思うことができるコンテンツを作り続けたいと
思います 場所を所有することに関連するこれらの質問を乗り越えたいのですが
、私は私のyoutubeのものを追求し続けたいと思いますどのように
この特定の家
を選んだのですか？
食器洗い機
4ベッドルームスペースの構造的完全性は、
靴のクローゼットの主な理由をクリアしました。これは問題ではないので
、東京で可能な限りお金を節約
し、可能であれば田舎に残すことを計画して
います。 東京に住んでいると
お金を節約するのは基本的に不可能だと思う
ので、この
コメントを見
ました。田舎に住んでお金を節約したいというのは、これは正しいアプローチでは
ないようでした。
だから私はできる 今のところこれについて詳しく話すことはありません
が
、東京でお金を節約することは非常に困難です。できれば東京から
出て行く次のビデオでこれについてもっと話します。
田舎では
もっと安いユニットを手に入れることができ
、朝の通勤やそのようなことをする必要がないので、より多くのお金
を節約することができます。
家主に
家賃の約1か月分の贈り物をするために、
引っ越しの
際に前の家の所有者も
同様の習慣があります。これ
は良い質問なので、私たちの場所は
基本的に新しいユニットでした。 以前は所有者
でしたが、引っ越したことはなかったので
、新しい場所では実際にはできません。
贈り物などをする
必要はありませんが、以前に所有していた場所に引っ越した場合は
とても素敵で、おそらくカスタムだと思います
少なくとも彼らにある種の
プレゼントを贈るのは難しいですが、彼らが
その場所を売るつもりなら、とにかく誰かにそれを買ってもらいたい
ので
、あなたがその場所を買っているのは彼らへのあなたの贈り物のようなものであり、あなたはそれがあなた
への彼らの贈り物であることを知っています
彼らはその場所を売っているので、私以外で
は、50ドルや100ドルのようなものはわかりませんが、
そうそう、素敵な食べ物など
、追加料金はかかりませ
んが、10,000ドル相当の一般的なもののように注意してください
不動産業者との取引手数料は
大丈夫なので、あと5、6問はあると思いますので、
続けていきましょう。外国人として一人でいるために
、どのような追加の手順を踏む必要があり
ましたか。
前のビデオとこのビデオで
続けるつもりですあなたは厳格になりました
かあなたは
日本人ではないのであなたはより厳しい規制を受けました
かええと私は
これについても話し合ったと思います私は
あなたに0.85パーセントを知って支払わなければなりませんでした 興味のある
wh 州のように非常に低い
ですが、あなたは日本の正確な日本人よりもさらに低くなる可能性が
あり、私
はその保証保証人
ガリンをうまく取得しなけれ
ばならなかったので、永住権を持っていないのであなたもそうしなければなりませんでした
ですから
、
土地のアワードが外国人に貸し出されないために考慮できなかった物件がいくつか
あったのに、アワードを置いているために考慮できなかった物件がいくつかありました。
私も東京の大都市圏に住んでいたので、田舎
にはたくさんの
家があります。
人口
問題は本当に大丈夫なので、話せますか？
これについては以前
はどんな形の差別も扱ったことはありませんでしたが
、外国人と日本人の比率を知っているようになると、
私は良い場所に住んでいます。
日本人が上手い人なら問題ないですよね
、東京の外にたくさんの家があるようなことに関しては、
先ほどあきおさんと、
お年寄りがやっているような廃屋のように話しました。
子供たちが引っ越してきて
、小さなアパートのようになりたいと思っているので、家を売るの
です。私は
、20歳や30歳のような古い場所のように
、また、
地震など
で、モダンな場所と
中東の年金の敵が
いるほうがいいと思います。恥ずかしいことですが、続けましょう。
モダンな日本のトイレなどが
好きな食器洗い機が好きです。 しゃがんだトイレのように扱え
ない日本人は、このような
大金を稼ぐと、お金を視覚的に見せないという話を聞きまし
た。
このような大金は
、クレがなくても同じです。
クレジットカードがない場合も、クレジットカード
がない場合は、自分でお金を払って自分で
名前を付け
て、車や家の代金を支払うときに名前を付け
ます。そうであれば、
実際に銀行に現金を持ってきた
からです。 日本の他の銀行から送るのに十分な時間がありませんでした
が
、それは非常に多額だったので、
あなたが知らなかったであろう
ずっと、そして私がそれを与えたとき、それは一種のブリーフケースのようなものでした 彼が
基本的に知っている人は大丈夫そうだね
大丈夫そうだねそうだね私はそうだろうそうだ
ほとんどの人は
実際にクレジットカードで変化していると思い
ますあなたがクレジットカードを使い始めている人は
ますます
あなたが車や家の代金を払うときにあなた自身があなたの名前を作るの
です
か 車とあなたが取る
ローンを組む場合は、
通常の標準名を使用する
必要があります。何を求めているのか完全にはわかりませんが、人々は
クレジットカードを使用し
ます。そのような状況で
は、個人情報を提供する必要があります。
もっと質問を続けましょう
大丈夫犬のボウルもう一度家で
オカルトまたは神秘的な電話をしましたか彼女は
私に大丈夫だと言ったので
日本で家を買うのは難しい
と思いますかええとそうです私はそうしますがおそらく難しいと思います
私の兄がちょうど南カリフォルニアのカリフォルニアでコンドミニアムを購入したように、最初の先進国
では、彼はそれが非常に
複雑で、私
よりも自分自身のためにかなりうまくやっていると
言ったので、おそらく彼は同じくらい多くの事務処理をしなければならなかったことを意味します
私の理解では、家を購入するプロセスは
、家の代金を現金で支払わない限り、基本的に世界中のどこでも複雑だと思いますが
、最終的には家を購入することになります。
家やコンドミニアムなどを所有する
ことになったので、1か月分の努力をし
なくても、結局は価値があると
思います。おっと、
最後の質問が1つあります。 これ
が最後の質問
です。日本で家を買うことを真剣に
考えているなら、まだ若いので
、ジェットプログラムに参加して、自由な時間に仕事をして、
すべてのお金を投資してみて
ください。大丈夫なので、これは
質問これは
私が話したいと思ったメモですので
、これについて簡単に話し
ます。ビデオで紹介します。
日本で家を買うことを真剣に考えているなら、私の
番号は私の一般的な作品です。 できれ
ばジェットプログラムで日本に来ることをお勧めし
ます。それは、ジェット
プログラムは
大学を卒業したばかりの人に非常によく支払われ、
あなたが仕事をすることができるたくさんのスキルを持っている必要
がないからです。 朝8時
から4時か5時くらい
学校によっては3時半くらい 毎日
、仕事以外でかなりの自由時間を過ごすことができるので、現在の為替レートで約
3,000米ドルからおそらく2,800米ドルを稼ぐことができる
ので、
彼らが支払うジェットプログラムはすべてを手に入れることができます
保険など
はおそらくそうなるでしょうし、ジェット
プログラムはあなたがどこに住んでいても同じように支払うので、
あなたは日本の非常に安い場所に住むことができ
、あなたはまだそれを手に入れるのでたくさんのお金を節約する
ことができます 良い給料比較的良い
給料そしてあなたがジェットプログラムに参加しているならあなたは
あなたのスキルセットを開発するためのより多くの自由な
時間
があるでしょう ジェットプログラム私は
自由な時間をすべて日本語を勉強し、日本語で
創造的な執筆を行い
、そのスキルセットを開発することに費やしました。これにより、現在行って
いる日本のコメディコンテンツを作成し、
このPRを購入することができました。
日本での運用なので、私が
言いたいのは
、10年後
、20年後、今15歳か20歳で、日本に
来たばかりの場合、将来
日本で家を買うことを真剣に考えているかどうかです。 または、今日本に行こうとしているだけの場合は
、ジェットプログラムが
最適なオプションです。高額の支払いを開始し、仕事
以外の時間に十分な時間をとって
、状況に対応できるスキルセットを開発し続けることができるからです。
将来、
まだ比較的若いときに
、日本で不動産を購入したり、日本でローンを組んだりできる可能性のある場所に
いることを私は言いたいと思っ
ています。 可能であればお金を節約して
、ジェットプログラムでそれ
をしましょう。これもまた、かなりの金額を得る
ことができ、安い場所にいる場合は
、基本的にすべてのお金を節約できます。
食べ物のための追加の100200のように、ジェット
プログラムは良いオプションです
お金を節約してあなたのスキルを開発してみてください etokこの
ビデオはもう1
時間ですすみません1時間ここで終了します
ここでもう1つ
言及したのは
、多くの人がこのスタイルのビデオを気に入っているようで、本当に驚いたことです。
私の通常のコンテンツと比べて、かなりの嫌いなもののように
なるだろうし、おそらくこれはビデオに
なるでしょう。なぜなら、今は単一の
インスタンスではないので
、予見できるようにこれを行うつもりだと言っています
将来は
興味がありますが、
元のビデオはかなりうまくいき、
私が話すのは楽しかったので、ええと、
他のトピック
について多くの質問があったので、
人々はそうなると思います
私の
通常の日本のコメディコンテンツに加えて、それについて聞くことに潜在的に興味があると思います。
この特定の種類のビデオのために台本や何かを準備する必要がないので、
基本的にそれを録画して、ただimmeすることができ
ます
スクリプトを書いたり、字幕を隠したり、
すべての作業を行ったりするのではなく、1週間かけてアップロードしてください。
このような別のシリーズを開始します。
ポッドキャストスタイルのようなもので
、日本の一般的な生活について話
します。
あなたが街のように住んでいるの
か、
街の
外に住んでいる
のか、知っておくべき良いことを知っ
ているお金を節約しましょう。 だから、もし
あなた
が私にそのようなことをすることに興味があればそれは良いことだと
思うなら、私は
1つか2つの追加のビデオ
が好きになると思いますが、あなたが次のようなビデオが欲しいと思うなら、フィードバックをください
それと私はあなたたちが興味を持っているならできるだけ多くのトピックをカバーしようとします
ので
、ここのビデオの男を再びとりとめのないカメ
はあなたの封じ込めサポートに感謝します
そしてまたあなたと
話すのを楽しみにしています